good morning
the need for international solidarity
and multilateral cooperation is
more conspicuous than ever
the norwegian nobel committee has
decided
to award the nobel peace prize for
2020 to the world
food programme for its efforts
to combat hunger
for its contribution to bettering
conditions
for peace in conflict affected areas
and for acting as a driving force
in efforts to prevent the use of hunger
as a weapon of war and conflict
the world food programme is the world's
largest humanitarian organization
addressing hunger and promoting food
security
last year the wfp
provided assistance to close to 1
million people in 88 countries
who are victims of acute food
insecurity and hunger
in 2015 eradicating hunger
was adopted as one of un's sustainable
development goals the wfp
is the un's primary instrument
for realizing this goal
in recent years the situation has
taken a negative turn in 2019
135 million people
suffered from acute hunger the highest
number
in many years most of the increase
was caused by war and armed conflict
the coronavirus pandemic has contributed
to a strong upsurge in the number of
victims of hunger in the world
in countries such as yemen the
democratic
republic of congo nigeria
south sudan and burkina faso
the combination of violent conflict and
the pandemic
has led to a dramatic rise in the number
of people living on the brink of
starvation
in the face of the pandemic the world
food programme has
demonstrated an impressive ability
to intensify its efforts
as the organization itself has stated
until the day we have a vaccine
food is the best vaccine against chaos
the world is in danger of experiencing
a hunger crisis of inconceivable
proportions if the world food programme
and other food assistance organizations
do not receive the financial support
they have requested
the link between hunger
and armed conflict is a vicious circle
war and conflict can cause
food insecurity and hunger
just as hunger and food insecurity
can cause latent conflicts to flare
up and trigger the use of violence
we will never achieve the goal of zero
hunger
unless we also put an end to
war and armed conflict
the norwegian nobel committee
wishes to emphasize that providing
assistance to increase
food security not only prevents hunger
but can also help to improve prospects
for stability
and peace the world food programme has
taken the lead
in combining humanitarian work with
peace efforts
through pioneering projects in south
america
africa and asia
the world food programme was an active
participant
in the diplomatic process that
culminated in may
2018 in the un security council's
unanimous adoption of resolution
2417 which
for the first time explicitly addresses
the link
between conflict and hunger
the security council also underscored un
member states obligation to help
ensure that food assistance reaches
those in need and condemned the use
of starvation as a method of
warfare
with this year's award the norwegian
nobel committee wishes
to turn the eyes of the world towards
the millions of people who suffer from
or face the threat of hunger
the world the world food programme plays
a key role
in multilateral cooperation on making
food security an instrument
of peace and has made a strong
contribution towards mobilizing
u.n member states to combat the use of
hunger
as a weapon of war and conflict
the organization contributes
daily to advancing the fraternity of
nations
referred to in alfred nobel's will
as the un's largest specialized
agency the world food programme
is a modern version of the peace
congresses
that the nobel peace prize is intended
to promote
the world food programme
the work of the world food programme to
the benefit of humankind
is an endeavor that all nations
of the world should be able
to endorse and support
thank you very much
you're looking at images live from oslo
the 2020
nobel peace prize in the announcement
you say that hunger is
often used as a weapon in conflicts
the 2020 nobel peace prize has been
awarded
to the un world food program
is that something of a surprise richard
yeah well i mean i think
it was not really in the top kind of
list that have been put together by
people who watch this every year
as kind of hot button things i didn't
see the world program
food program very high on the
bookkeepers kind of
uh betting uh stakes
but if you kind of pull back and think
about this examination
it makes sense so uh the nobel committee
has
a history of uh giving the award uh
two un institutions especially at points
in time where they are particularly
relevant to the situation going on at
the time
um they are making the case that
food security is very intimately tied a
weapon
of war yeah exactly right there and and
this is very much tied to
as well uh the pandemic from what we
heard right there the pandemic deepening
um food insecurity globally especially
in in countries in africa we heard about
congo
nigeria south sudan that's right so
making the point that
um conflict and food security are
intimately linked
the the corona crisis the pandemic
coming on top of that
creates a very severe risk of
of much greater worsening of those
crises
referring to some of the countries where
the world food programme has absolutely
been essential to
trying to stave our famine for instance
yemen which has been your
war-torn for years now we've all seen
the
terrible images that have come out of
yemen in recent years the world food
programme playing a critical role in
trying to keep the population
going there yeah the dependency in yemen
for example on
on the supplies coming from the u.n
world food program
um a driving force in the awarding of
uh the the uh peace prizes of course
alfred nobel's wish that
that this is tied to the peace congress
that was
just mentioned right there yeah of the
past and and there is a continuity
yeah and that was really specifically
brought up just in what we heard of
course
um and i think they also wanted to
highlight that
um they were acknowledging the world
through program not just for its mission
in itself but for the way in which it
works so it was very interesting the
very first thing that we heard
in the announcement was that the need
for global cooperation
is greater than ever at the moment so
of course that got me thinking all right
maybe we're about to hear the world
health organization you know in the
context of
pandemic and and they're using this to
say wait a minute
it's not just all about the coronavirus
there are other factors here
and i think this is also something they
quite often want to do with the nobel
peace prize is to draw attention to
issues that they feel are not getting
sufficient attention
and and this was clear when we heard
that that quote an unprecedented
crisis is looming yeah i mean that is
really shining the light on
um if in effect what was indicated and
what we heard there
specifically and knock on effect of the
pandemic collapse of supply lines and
and uh the breakdown of not only
um food supplies but the possibility to
travel in some of those regions as well
because of a lack of petrol
diesel and things like this i mean you
know the fear
of disruptions to food supplies is
something that's even hit
rich western countries this year isn't
it in the early stages of the pandemic
you'll remember here in berlin shopping
panic shopping
uh supermarkets suddenly emptied out of
all sorts of things
now of course that was quickly restored
but that was just a very very sort of
like in miniature tiny microscopic
version of the
of the problems that people face in
conflict zones
where they don't even have supermarkets
we saw other signals as well
as well as our our own need at the
grocery store there was a drop off and
in donations to to charitable
organizations as soon as this hit
uh the pandemic with people concerned
about their expenditures unemployment et
cetera
that's right and i mean this has been a
concern in many countries in the world
not just in water on countries
at the early stages of the pandemic
there was concern for instance in india
of course with an
enormous population enormous number of
people to feed
about whether there would be an impact
on food supply and security there that
did not pan out uh thankfully but i
think this is also a reminder that you
know this pandemic is still
by far not over in fact just yesterday
the number of new cases hit a new record
of 338 000 globally
so if this is continuing and especially
the global south is being more affected
as time passes the numbers we're talking
about for 2019 135
million people suffering from food
insecurity and clearly according to the
the committee the that number expected
in 2020 to be increasing that's right
it's quite interesting to think also
about one thing that the
in the announcement towards the end of
it was um where
uh uh barrett-rice anderson said um
this is something you know this mission
is something that the entire world ought
to be able to get behind
and i think that is interesting that
they did choose this organization
because
it is quite likely to be a less
controversial award it is
it's more neutral i thought this was
there's a lot of wisdom in this choice
uh
to that degree that this is an
organization no matter what your
political stripe you can get behind this
yeah i think it's an interesting choice
from that point of view because
the world is polarized the the debate
around the world oil health organization
is polarized you know the united states
just pulled out of it this year
uh donald trump accusing it of being
essentially a chinese
front of some kind um i think the nobel
committee seem in this choice to have
decided
they don't want to go into that kind of
controversy they don't want to
fuel um some of the uh
conspiratorial kind of theories around
the coronavirus which of course have
emerged in various sort of
niches of the internet and they want to
draw attention
to a major issue that is not getting
enough attention right now
you